surge in votes has put lampedusa not for
the first time in the crosshairs of
European political debate what's not up
for argument this tiny Island can't cope
thousands of new arrivals have
overwhelmed the Reception Center built
for 680. basic needs are going unmet
and I've seen some people for goodness
they haven't eaten anything what I want
is
it's just like prison for most nights
here are spent in the open days seeking
whatever help there is
even to get a little bit of bread has
been difficult this is not good it's
been five days we have been saying
please help us get out of this place and
yet more still come hundreds on Saturday
alone lampedusa is less than 150
kilometers from the Tunisian coast and
has become the main sea route from North
Africa into Europe This Spike being
blamed partly on calm weather partly on
troubled negotiations between the EU and
Tunisia
shouts the Island's Deputy Mayor saying
the residents are tired and want to
return to a life based on tourism and
fishing
the state is putting us in a position
where we have to leave our own Island if
they build another camp or prison or
they keep immigration uncontrolled then
it's the end for us for a prime minister
voted into power on Promises of solving
the migration issue the chaos in land
producer is both a problem and an
opportunity I have written to the
president of the European commission to
ask her to come with me to lampedusa to
personally realized the gravity of the
situation we face and to immediately
accelerate the implementation of the
agreement with Tunisia by transferring
the agreed resources
Ursula Wonderland will be here on Sunday
along with Georgia Maloney but it's far
from Clear exactly how much of what she
wants Italy's Prime Minister will get
one demand almost certainly well Out Of
Reach the idea of an EU Naval blockade
that would prevent migrant boats from
reaching these Shores some of the
pressure is being relieved transfers to
the mainland we're continuing even
through Saturday night but this remains
another in lampedusa's long history of
migration emergencies the imperative is
on the Italian and EU leaderships to
find a solution Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera
lampedusa
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera